oui bonsoir je suis très très heureux du
résultat les les neuf et reçoivent nous
ont placés avec la libération le long de
la gauche largement en tête de cette
élection de premier tour je voudrais les
remercier et la dynamique et créer une
autre côté et nous allons maintenant
faire une belle campagne de deuxième
tour pour assembler les déversoirs
question de lilian melet florent sainte
fare garnot bonsoir
vous dites dynamique parce
qu'effectivement au total des voix si on
regarde par rapport à la dernière
élection à nevers mille voix de moins
pour le candidat du parti socialiste au
premier tour à coups de choses près ça
veut dire que nevers qu'à une ville
socialiste très ancrée et toucher aussi
parce ce vote de désaveu
je crois surtout que la situation locale
avec cette liste a énormément compté
puisque naturellement nos concitoyens en
but une offre politique très large et
ont eu besoin de se positionner ce que
je vois c'est qu'ils ont manifestement
garder leur confiance à leur maire au
rassemblement de la gauche et que les
conditions sont réunies pour que nous
puissions l'emporter cette liste vous en
parliez dont cinq qui peuvent se
maintenir au deuxième tour et ce qu'il
va y avoir des discussions notamment
avec données thuriau qui réalise un très
bon score également
écouter en tant que candidat arrivé en
tête je vais bien sûr laisser chacun
s'adresser à la liste que je représente
elle nous allons voir ce qui importe
pour moi c'est de créer la dynamique sur
le projet que je défends de
redéveloppement nevers de solidarité la
loire au coeur l'emploi priorité numéro
un le centre ville nous allons voir il
ya maintenant des discussions possibles
si certains souhaitent maples ils le
feront mais de mon côté je regarde le
deuxième tour et c'est ça qui m'importe
nous sommes en bonne position pour
l'emporter